>> THIS YEAR THE LEADING
REPUBLICAN RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR
IS A CLOSEST THING TO A TRUMP
CLONE THAT I HAVE EVER SEEN IN
YOUR STATE.
CALIFORNIA, KEEP GAVIN NEWSOM
AND SEND A MESSAGE TO THE
NATION.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
CARLEY: THERE HE IS PRESIDENT
BIDEN HEADING TO CALIFORNIA TO
DEFEND EMBATTLED GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM AS VOTERS AT THE POLLS IN
THE GOLDEN STATE TODAY.
TODD: FOX NATION HOST TOMI
LAHREN JOINS US NOW.
TOMI, DOESN’T JOE BIDEN’S
VISITED JUST REINFORCE THIS
NOTION THAT IT’S REALLY THE
WASHINGTON ELITE THAT WANT TO
PROP UP GAVIN NEWSOM AND WANT
HIM IN THERE IN THE FIRST PLACE
AND NOT THE COMMON FOLK.
>> NOT JUST THE WASHINGTON
ELITE.
HOLLYWOOD ELITE.
BIG TECH ELITE SPECIAL INTEREST
LIKE THE ALMIGHTY’S TEA PARTY’S
UNION ALL OF THE ELITES THAT
WERE ABLE TO WEATHER THE PAN
PANDEMIC AND COVID TYRANNY THAT
GAVIN NEWSOM PLACED ON THAT
STATE THEY ARE ALL THE ONES
PROPPING UP GAVIN NEWSOM SAYING
THEY WANT TO KEEP HIM IN THE
STATE BECAUSE THEY ARE THE ONES
THAT HAVEN’T BEEN AFFECTED BY
HIS DISASTROUS LEADERSHIP.
IT’S THE AVERAGE PEOPLE ON BOTH
THE LEFT AND THE RIGHT IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE SAYING, YOU
KNOW WHAT?
NOT GOOD FOR THE GOLDEN STATE.
50 LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
IT’S ABOUT TIME WE START ACTING
LIKE IT.
CARLEY: THE "L.A. TIMES"
EDITORIAL BOARD CAME OUT WITH A
PIECE DEFENDING GAVIN NEWSOM.
THEY SAY THE MANY REASONS TO
VOTE NO ON RECALLING GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM MANY PEOPLE ARE MAD
ABOUT HOW THE PANDEMIC UP ENDED
THEIR LIVES THAT’S NOT NEWSOM’S
FAULT AND PUNISHING HIM WILL NOT
FIX ANYTHING.
IN FACT, IT WOULD LIKELY MAKE
THINGS WORSE FOR EVERYONE IN THE
STATE WOULD LOVE FOR YOU TO
RESPOND TO THAT.
>> THIS IS WHAT DEMOCRATS DO.
THEY CANNOT TAKE ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR ANYTHING THAT THEY HAVE
DONE.
EVEN IF YOU DON’T BELIEVE THAT
THE HORRIBLE LEADERSHIP OF GAVIN
NEWSOM THROUGH THE PANDEMIC WAS
PROBLEMATIC, YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
CALIFORNIA PRE-PANDEMIC.
BEFORE THE FIRST COVID CASE WAS
EVER RECORDED IN THAT STATE.
YOU STILL ARE GOING GREAT THINGS
THAT’S WHAT THE "L.A. TIMES"
CANNOT OUTLINE.
THEY ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT HOW
GREAT HE HAS HANDLED THE
HOMELESS CRISIS.
HOW GREAT HE HAS ENFORCED THE
BORDER.
HOW HE HAS DECREASED LAWLESSNESS
AND FELON CODDLING IN HIS STATE.
HOW HE HAS LOWERED GAS PRICES
AND RED TAPE AND REGULATION.
THEY ARE NOT TOUTING ANY OF THAT
BECAUSE IT DOESN’T EXIST.
HIS LEADERSHIP WAS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND IT BECAME IMPOSSIBLE TO
IGNORE BECAUSE OF COVID.
BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE, GAVIN
NEWSOM’S LEADERSHIP WAS WORSE
BUT NOW IT WAS BAD MANY, MANY
YEARS AGO WHEN HE WAS IN CHARGE
OF SAN FRANCISCO AND DEMOCRATS
HAVE BEEN RUINING THAT STATE FOR
YEARS.
IT IS TIME TO MAKE A CHANGE.
NOT JUST WITH GAVIN NEWSOM BUT
WITH THE DEMOCRAT LEADERSHIP OF
THAT STATE THAT HAS FAILED THAT
STATE.
TODD: MEANTIME JOE BIDEN’S
VACCINE MANDATES CRITICIZED WHEN
SO MANY AMERICANS REFUSE TO
WORK.
GET THIS THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS
100 MILLION AMERICANS WILL BE
AFFECTED BY JOE BIDEN’S VACCINE
MANDATE.
WHAT’S YOUR MESSAGE TO THOSE
100 MILLION, TOMI?
WHAT’S YOUR MESSAGE TO THE WHITE
HOUSE AS WELL?
>> MY MESSAGE TO THOSE
100 MILLION AMERICANS PLUS RIGHT
NOW SITTING IN A POSITION EITHER
GET A VACCINE OR LOSE THEIR
JOB -- NOW, LET ME BE CLEAR IF
YOU WANT TO GET THE VACCINE
BECAUSE YOU BELIEVE IT’S THE
BEST DECISION TO YOUR HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND THAT’S YOUR PERSONAL
DECISION THAT YOU HAVE MADE YOUR
DOCTOR, THEN THAT IS ONE THING,
IF YOU ARE SIMPLY GETTING THE
VACCINE TO KEEP YOUR JOB, THAT
IS WRONG, THAT IS UNAMERICAN.
BUT CAN WE REALLY BE SURPRISED?
WE STARTED HEMORRHAGING OUR
RIGHTS TO THE GOVERNMENT OVER A
YEAR AND A HALF AGO.
AND NOW THEY CONTINUE TO TAKE.
YOU GIVE THEM AN INCH, THEY WILL
TAKE A MILE.
THESE MANDATES ARE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
I HOPE THAT THEY WILL BE
CHALLENGED.
AND TO THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE,
PLEASE UNDERSTAND THIS.
FOLKS EXEMPTION IS THAT THEY
BELIEVE IN JESUS CHRIST, THEY
BELIEVE IN THEIR PERSONAL HEALTH
AND THEIR PERSONAL CHOICES AND
FREEDOM.
THEY DON’T BELIEVE IN
GOVERNMENT.
AND THEY DON’T BELIEVE IN FAUCI
AND THEY ARE GOING TO MAKE THEIR
DECISIONS FOR THEMSELVES SO THE
RESPONSE SHOULD BE WE WILL SEE
YOU IN COURT.
CARLEY: A LOT OF REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS ALREADY SAID THAT VERY
THING.
NO SURPRISE THERE.
THEY WERE HAVING THIS VERY
CONVERSATION ON MSNBC ABOUT THE
VACCINE MANDATE WHEN THEIR HOST
STEPHANIE SAID IT SHOULDN’T BE
HARD TO FOLLOW BECAUSE ALL YOU
HAVE TO DO IS THIS TAKE A
LISTEN.
>> IF YOU DO NOT WANT TO GET
VACCINATED, YOU CAN WORK FROM
HOME.
YOU CAN HOME SCHOOL YOUR
CHILDREN.
YOU CAN SHOP ONLINE.
SO, WHERE IS THIS COMING FROM
PEOPLE SAYING I’M NOW BEING
FORCED TO BE VACCINATED?
>> JUST WORK FROM HOME, SHOP
ONLINE, NEVER LEAF YOUR HOUSE.
>> I’M GOING TO PROVIDE A
COUNTER POINT TO THAT HOW ABOUT
THIS?
IF AFTER OVER A YEAR AND A HALF
IF YOU ARE STILL AFRAID OF
CORONAVIRUS, YOU CAN STAY HOME.
THE REST OF US ARE GOING TO GO
ABOUT LIVING OUR NORMAL LIVES.
WE’RE GOING GO TO WORK.
WE’RE GOING TO GO SCHOOL.
WE’RE GOING TO HAVE FAMILY
GATHERINGS.
WE’RE GOING TO HAVE FOOTBALL
GAMES AND LIVE NORMALLY.
IF THIS TERRIFIES YOU, YOU ARE
THE ONE THAT CAN STAY HOME AS
FOR THE REST OF US, WE ARE GOING
TO BE FREE AMERICANS IN THIS
FREE COUNTRY THAT WE LIVE.
IN.
TODD: ALSO FOR THE JOBS THAT YOU
CAN’T WORK FROM HOME AT THOSE
ARE THE ONES WE NEED TO FILL
CONSTRUCTION WORKER WORK FROM
HOME CHEF IN A RESTAURANT WORK
FROM HOME?
KIND OF TOUGH.
CARLEY: MAYBE NOT WEAR MASKS OUT
IN THE GREENHOUSE.
POINTLESS.
TOMI, THANK YOU FOR JOINING US